hong kong es uno de esos lugares quiero
necesitar ser presentado quien no lo
conoce todo el mundo lo conoce si todo
el sur de china
hablamos de una ciudad viva agitada en
permanente movimiento pero sobre todo
hablamos de una ciudad de grandes
contrastes
en hong kong no te puede sorprender ver
camiones ruinosos junto a coches de
altísima gama edificios prácticamente en
ruinas pegados literalmente a lujosos
rascacielos o restaurantes con varias
estrellas michelín frente a puestos de
comida cómo decirlo con dudosas
garantías higiénicas
eso sí podéis creerme hay un elemento
común denominador en hong kong todos los
huecos son pequeños
[Música]
no importa si hablamos de un centro
comercial carísimo o de una improvisada
tienda tradicional en hong kong cada
metro está hiper aprovechado de todas
formas fueron dos las cosas que más me
llamaron la atención la primera vez que
pisé esta ciudad
primero los rascacielos que se
construyen con andamios de bambú que si
son muy resistentes pero impresionan y
lo segundo la enorme densidad de gente
que hay muchas zonas de la ciudad amigos
un consejo antes de seguir si no te
gustan las grandes concentraciones de
gente olvida la esta ciudad no es para
ti pero no nos desviemos hong kong ha
sido claramente uno de los grandes
milagros económicos del siglo 20 de
hecho fue el modelo tomado por el
mismísmo muy con prima para defender sus
tesis en favor del libre mercado
si usted quiere ver como el mercado
libre realmente trabaja debe venir a
este lugar fijaros tras la segunda
guerra mundial
hong kong era una ciudad de apenas unos
seiscientos mil habitantes y un ingreso
equivalente ojo a la cuarta parte del de
reino unido es decir en una ciudad pobre
sesenta años más tarde la población
supera los siete millones de personas y
el ingreso per cápita se ha
prácticamente igualado al británico
bueno y si además tenemos en cuenta los
diferentes niveles de precios su pib per
cápita resulta muy superior al de reino
unido
y durante todo este tiempo hong kong no
solo se ha convertido en el cuarto mayor
centro financiero de todo el mundo y en
una de las diez plazas comerciales más
importantes sino que además yo diría
sobre todo ha sido un refugio para
millones de chinos que escaparon de la
pobreza y la violencia de la china de
mao en toda esta evolución ha tenido
mucho que ver el amplio ecosistema de
libertad económica que se respira en la
ciudad no no hablamos desde luego de un
paraíso libertario pero a día de hoy
hong kong es considerada como la
economía más libre de todo el mundo y la
cuarta donde más fácil resulta hacer
negocios no está mal verdad
[Música]
en cualquier caso sobre las claves de su
desarrollo económico ya hablaremos en
otro vídeo hoy nos vamos a centrar en la
vertiente política y en las amenazas que
se ciernen sobre su estructura
institucional y qué amigos puede incluso
poner en riesgo el progreso de esta
ciudad para ello tenemos que empezar
innecesariamente por la paradoja a la
que se enfrenta con con casi una seña
identidad de la ciudad me explico
hong kong es china pero una china libre
o al menos más libre
un país dos sistemas
fue colonia británica hasta 1997 cuando
la ciudad volví a integrarse en china
algo que no ocurría desde el siglo 19
bien yo creo que a nadie nos puede caber
ninguna duda china era y es hoy en día
una dictadura una dictadura donde los
respetos a los derechos humanos y las
libertades civiles brillan por su
ausencia claro esto obligó a los
gobiernos de pekín y londres a negociar
una salida porque evidentemente ni los
ciudadanos de hong kong estaban
dispuestos a perder sus derechos ni
londres podrían tolerar que esta ciudad
cayese en manos del autoritarismo chino
no al menos completamente tendrás muchas
negociaciones en 1984 se llegó a un
acuerdo conocido como la declaración
conjunta chino británica que establecía
que durante los siguientes 50 años desde
el traspaso de soberanía se aplicaría en
hong kong un modelo político distinto al
de la china continental así con con paso
a ser una región administrativa especial
donde rige la conocida como ley básica
que le otorga a sus ciudadanos derechos
y libertades absolutamente inimaginables
en cualquier otro lugar del país a
excepción eso sí de macao que como vimos
en otro vídeo también se integró en
china con este mismo sistema el
presidente sigue en ping a valor la
implementación de la política de un país
dos sistemas en hong kong y reiteró la
insistencia del gobierno central en este
principio los ciudadanos de hong kong
tienen reconocidas las libertades de
expresión y prensa publicación reunión
asociación e incluso manifestación
tienen acceso pleno a los medios de
comunicación internacionales y la
censura virtual la conocida como ciber
muralla
[Música]
y concón se puede utilizar facebook o
google sin ningún problema
además hong kong tiene su propia moneda
su propia política de inmigración y
aduanas su policía
incluso sus tribunales propios pues bien
en un primer momento las cosas
discurrieron francamente bien el
crecimiento económico ha acompañado los
hongkoneses mantenían su estatus de
libertad y podían aplicar políticas
propias y además hong kong se convertía
de facto en la puerta natural para las
inversiones extranjeras en china sin
embargo al cabo de unos pocos años
comenzaron a aparecer las nubes negras
en el horizonte y situaciones
democráticos si la ley básica reconoce
derechos civiles pero no hace lo mismo
con la democracia
de hecho el gobierno chino tiene de
facto en el control del parlamento y del
poder ejecutivo en esta región como de
la siguiente manera primero en el
parlamento de hong kong sólo la mitad de
los diputados escogen mediante sufragio
universal la otra mitad la escoge un
grupo cerrado formado en la práctica por
empresarios en instituciones afines a
pequeños cuando las fracciones pro
chinas impidieron la juramentación de
diputados independentistas los
partidarios de pekín abandonaron el
recinto lo que motivó la suspensión de
la sesión por falta de quórum según
el jefe ejecutivo esto es el presidente
del gobierno se escoge no por los
ciudadanos sino por un comité de 1200
personas vinculadas de una forma u otra
al partido comunista chino tercero todos
los cargos públicos deben jurar su
lealtad y su compromiso con china de tal
forma que la puerta para considerar
determinadas posiciones políticas como
ilegítimas queda abierta autonomía
autodeterminación y libertad el tribunal
supremo de hong kong dictaminó este
martes que los dos legisladores
independentistas inmersos en una
polémica por la forma en la que juraron
el cargo perderán sus escaños cuarto la
ley básica de autonomía de hong kong que
da en cualquier caso subordinada a la
asamblea popular china ahora bien el
pacto firmado entre china y reino unido-
exigía que a partir de 2017 todos los
ciudadanos de hong kong pudieran elegir
mediante sufragio universal al
presidente del ejecutivo y aquí amigos
es donde china comenzó a faltar a la
palabra dada
el engaño chino y las movilizaciones
sociales el 31 de agosto de 2014 la
asamblea nacional de pekín puso en
marcha la reforma electoral para elegir
al jefe de gobierno de esta región
especial y precisamente aquí apareció la
sorpresa vamos a si queremos los
llamados estándares internacionales como
proponen algunos pequeños grupos en hong
kong terminaríamos en una sociedad
caótica si pekín reconocía el sufragio
universal pero bajo esta reforma los
ciudadanos de hong kong únicamente
hubiesen podido elegir entre dos o tres
candidatos seleccionados previamente por
el partido comunista chino la democracia
popular lo llama a los pocos días
comenzaron las movilizaciones civiles
lideradas en un primer momento por
estudiantes algunos de apenas 17 años
sí
[Música]
claro es comprensible como decirle a un
joven como muchos de los que nos estáis
viendo libre formado y con pleno acceso
a los medios de comunicación y en
internet que a pesar de todo va a tener
que estar sometido a la dictadura china
que va a tener que resignarse es una
situación complicada la reacción de las
autoridades a las primeras huelgas y
movilizaciones no fue del todo amable
decidieron utilizar la mano dura y la
represión policial sin embargo el
resultado en la verdad fue el contrario
que imaginaban
no nos iremos a casa no sólo yo nadie se
irá a casa hasta la victoria ante o
huawei móviles por el miedo a quedar
sometidos a pekín y también por la
solidaridad con los estudiantes
detenidos cada vez más gente se lanzó a
la calle pronto una gran movilización
ciudadana ocupó el centro de hong kong
la represión policial recurrió al
lanzamiento de gases lacrimógenos y gas
pimienta a lo que la población respondió
abriendo sus paraguas para mitigar el
efecto de los gases así se fraguó el
nombre por el que ya se conoce a este
movimiento la revolución de los paraguas
en la ocupación del centro financiero
duró 79 días y desde entonces la
conflictividad ha continuado con brotes
esporádicos de violencia o protestas y
con jóvenes cada vez más escorados no
sólo hacia la exigencia de más
democracia sino también hacia tesis
independentistas algo que por cierto
china ya ha dicho no va a tolerar bajo
ninguna circunstancia aunque tenga que
hacer uso de la bota militar por cierto
hace poco china diego a secuestrar a
cinco libreros a cinco ciudadanos de
hong kong por difundir ideas contra el
control de la metrópoli y esto es algo
que cada vez preocupa más a los
ciudadanos de esta ciudad la que se
encuentra en libertad bajo fianza relató
el jueves en una conferencia de prensa
cómo fue detenido cuando viajaba el
continente y fue interrogado durante
meses sin tener acceso a un abogado oa
su familia en este contexto en
septiembre de 2016 se celebraron
elecciones al parlamento y muchos de los
líderes de las protestas fueron elegidos
como diputados sin embargo sus llamadas
contra pekín y en favor de la
independencia han vuelto a abrir la caja
de pandora de momento son ya dos los
diputados apartados de su cargo y pekín
a amenazar con apartar a otros quince
ojos
porque los derechos civiles solo están
protegidos nominalmente hasta 2047 y la
intromisión de china en los asuntos de
la región es cada vez mayor y esto tiene
un coste no sólo en términos políticos
también económicos porque incrementa el
riesgo percibido por los inversores de
hecho esta es seguro una de las causas
que han propiciado que en los últimos
años y el crecimiento de singapur haya
sido muy superior al de hong kong bien
tú qué opinas de ven los ciudadanos
hongkoneses luchar por su libertad
quiere realmente china terminar con los
derechos civiles en esta región si te ha
gustado el vídeo dale a like y si aún no
lo has hecho no te olvides de
suscribirte al canal lo puedes hacer
pulsando en este botón un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]